I had one experience with uh Johnny uh
Knoxville Knoxville
so I'm sitting on a Deus
with uh
um Mike oh that it wasn't Knoxville it
was me when I ran into Mike Tyson yes he
died it was you I broke my nose on Mike
Tyson's fist right I'm gonna described
you something that that uh Mike Tyson
and I looked at each other
like I can't believe so you're sitting
on one side of Mike I'm sitting the
other side of Mike and where it was a a
roast of some kind and and I I believe
you were in on the conversation we're
talking about all kinds of the religion
and what he's doing and and the boxing
and it was great I had a great time on
the Deus with him talking
now it's over ah thank you very much
everybody
Johnny says to
uh to uh I said to him to Mike to Mike
hold your fist out yeah
what I hold your fist out
screen like this and he puts his fist
down
he goes across the stage and runs into
his fist yeah so we both look at each
other what is going on and he says
it didn't work let's do it again and
Mike says what run into your fist again
many times
when it was bleeding ah
what the [__]
is what everybody says
is a normal response to that what the
[__] because you there there's a chip
missing
or more kindly you've got an additional
chip okay
you and your crew but some of the crew
have only half that chip because they go
oh geez you may not get you want me to
throw myself on the cactus
okay you know like I'm going to be
reluctant to do this Steve does it three
or four times right the other guy the
other guys there's more than one to go
oh God it's gonna hurt like hell and
then you got to take tweezes and pluck
all the things
that's crazy crazy it it is and once
again when people what is it tell me
what that is that is um the highest
level of attention seeking
and and it's not that I how you said
that more than once you really mean it
yeah but you're so bright you know
you're good looking you've got great
feet
you could do it you could be you could
be foot commercials I don't know about
that
yeah
I I uh you know my my desire for
attention outweighs my need for Comfort
wow and um and and again I I uh quickly
where does that come from uh well you
don't have to be Sigmund Freud to
imagine that a lack of attention and
supervision from my parents plus growing
up in five different countries where I
was always the new kid in school and
always looking for attention yeah and
you got attention by saying hit me not
hit me like at one point I unscrewed a
salt shaker and consumed all the salt in
it to try to impress uh my classmates
did you blow up the next day it was the
water retention
I've learned since then that that was a
particularly bad idea well a lot of
those ideas
for your longevity the fact that you and
I are sitting here now is like
I was looking forward to it to talk to
you about it because it's so unusual
it's
you know
it probably could be likened to the
tradition of monks piercing their nose
and their ears and and putting uh
needles through them and I I I think
what they were after was their ability
to control their mind so that the pain
wasn't overwhelming is that what you're
doing you had the guy come over your
house one day and stick the needle
through your hand right didn't you right
did you actually stick that through your
hand yeah
those are those special effects is that
that one you just actually put a needle
through your hand and then you call it
magic
did it hurt a little bit Yeah it hurt a
little bit so wait a minute does pain
tolerance come into this again it's uh
like if I had uh an extraordinary
tolerance for pain
um then there would be no reaction
action to to the the experience of the
pain and what makes the the jackass
movies and a lot of the things that I do
is the reaction so so feeling the pain
is really uh integral to the art and but
the expression of the feeling of the
pain is also there isn't it yeah I mean
you could scream and faint that wouldn't
be as theatrical as saying oh my God the
search I can't tell you I'm going to
tell you how much it hurts as a fire
burning into my head I can't move my
fingers screaming and fainting is also
highly entertaining I think but it's
momentary the mother thing he's dead you
know he ceases to to entertain you right
so you got to stay stay conscious to be
really entertaining he expressed himself
pretty well when he had the beehive on
his dick
they actually strapped the queen bee to
my weiner
no come on I missed that one yeah that
was gonna happen uh I got stung about 12
times I didn't make your wiener bigger I
didn't um my wiener got away with it I I
took one on the balls 12 times yeah I
got to install them so would you swell
up
nah I I appear to be not allergic to
bees well I was gonna say if nothing
happened then it was like a sweet
reminiscence it was it was it was uh it
was what we call a trailer moment
but but did they fuzz over your weeder
so because it was an R-rated movie
but if it were showing on television
which they are yeah you'd have to fuzz
out they will the very excitement I mean
that's the exactly did you get an
erection I did not I did not get an
arrest did it shrink but I looked pretty
good at the moment you know for you know
like how did you try and get it up I
didn't try to get it up but I I was
pretty happy with where I was in my
flaccid State as far as not being too
contracted yeah you think with like the
blood flow going there you'd get an
erection you must have had a good lawyer
to have a
good a good nonsense
I do not disclose it was a it was it was
a nice warm day
man I'm telling you
one more question or another question
do you anticipate it do you think
it's going to be a B on my weiner that's
going to be that's exciting
I got to give the person who thought of
that a bonus yeah closer to thousands of
bees I found out that it was happening
after I arrived on the set that day the
actual bit had not yet been assigned to
anybody and when I heard about it I said
oh that's all me let me get that one did
anybody fight you on it nobody fought me
on it everybody uh
everybody's let me have it do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude good